like the story we have to talk about
right now is that belarus
here i'm using the daily beasts i love
it they say belarus issues dire world
war iii warning as it gets ready to send
troops to ukraine they've also approved
russia staging nuclear weapons in
belarusian borders ukraine has said
they've already invaded you've got a
ukrainian journalist in poland telling
boris uh from the uk pm
that world war three has already started
and nato needs to intervene with a
no-fly zone and i'm sitting here like
this is like the most serious news i
think i've ever experienced in my adult
life i don't know if any i guess
you know look with um iraq afghanistan
and those wars
i wasn't really worried they were gonna
nuke us or or send you know waved or
wave of their own men you know what
though they said they could because that
was the whole thing they talked about
wmds and they were saying we have to go
over there because we don't find out
it's too late after they already knew us
and then it's funny because even though
they made up all these lies about how
saddam was close to getting a nuke and
how that was a wmd they said well we
weren't lying about weapons of mass
destruction because there were chemical
weapons there that can be considered
wmds
yeah i think there were i mean yeah yes
but that's different from nuclear
weaponry obviously when they were saying
weapons of mass destruction in the minds
of the public that construed an image of
nuclear weapons and then they said oh of
course there were wmds it was like
chemicals so so let's let's just put
layer upon layer on this one so we got
all this stuff happening and i'm like
okay it's kind of freaking out you know
kind of freaking me out but uh you know
we can all laugh here and make fun of
joe biden and you know if if there's one
thing joe biden's done is he's made us
all laugh that's true it's probably
something well that's the thing about
joe biden i said this as soon as he got
elected finally a president who can't
disappoint me yeah there's no possible
way
and uh you know he he makes us laugh
every now and again it's true it's true
and so yeah horrible situation going on
over there we don't want to make light
of it it is frightening in many ways but
one of the purposes of comedy is to be
able to
get people to to um
keep their spirits up through difficult
times so there's another thing that
happened um on tv
the president of belarus uh lukashenko
was pointing to a map that showed
uh what appeared to be the russian
military plan
from russia and belarus into ukraine but
there were several attack points drawn
on the map that haven't happened
and so of course a lot many in the media
are saying haven't happened yet as if
it's you know the actual plan that
russia has and now if that's true and i
don't know why it would be i don't know
what that map is it shows i think four
accurate attack factors that have
already occurred as well as several
others that make people think they might
occur because some are like right like
right after kharkiv there's like another
attack movement
is the implication that there's like
some planning or that's just their guess
the impli the implication well i don't
know why the president of belarus put
the map up like he was explaining like
here's what's happening but the
implication is that what they're saying
belarus an ally of russia they know what
the military plan is and they've
effectively shown the next move will be
to move into odessa and then into
moldova or they could be fake plans yeah
it could just be but but if it is it
could be fake the scary thing is and
maybe this is just
him trying to freak people out trying to
fog of war you know confuse people false
orders
or like psychological manipulation this
implies russia will invade another
country notably the the disputed
territory is transnistria which has
already got russian troops there which
could be then used by russia as a
staging ground to bypass ukrainian
defenses and then move through the
southwest of the country it might still
remain just a ukraine thing but
you've also got kaliningrad there's
there's a lot of crazy stuff here man so
um i don't know world war iii got a
glance the red lines on this i mean this
is like a daily mail article i'm looking
at i didn't i haven't investigated the
map but maybe those are red lines
indicating where infiltration has
already taken place like where there's
russian special forces awaiting action
because they said moldova's already
infiltrated crimea was already
infiltrated obviously and it looks like
a lot of parts of ukraine had already
been infiltrated on the map maybe
i don't know but i would i would imagine
more than it's a battle map or a fake
battle map
yeah i mean to what tim was saying about
the fact that there are certain places
where they're saying they're going to
attack they could they couldn't i have
absolutely no idea i will say this we
should um we should
believe the media about as much as we
would if they were reporting on anything
else oh yeah yeah i tweeted i love this
whenever anything in the media happens
i'm just going to call them the people
who believe jesse smaller no exactly
exactly you know during covert i was
like the people who believe jesus
malette are lecturing me on kovid and
then i tweeted and i got like 3 000
retweets then i tweeted the other day or
maybe this morning the people who
believe jesse smallett are lecturing me
on ukraine and it got like thousands of
retweets it's true fantastic no it's
true yeah and you're from mega country
dude i want to clear this up i saw you
on twitter trending that was awesome and
then i found out because you said i
don't like appeals to emotion is that
what it is appeal to emotion it's a type
of argument an ad hominem or an ad
emotional attack or something it's an
it's an appeal to a motion so they're
you know yes i was training for that and
they're trying first they got it wrong
um there's a video clip of zalensky
talking about you know civilians dying
but the translator is crying as he's
saying it
that's what i'm talking about so
propaganda so that was the news story
that went viral appeal to emotion what
you were talking about is a logical
fallacy characterized by the
manipulation of the recipient's emotions
correct in order to win an argument so i
understand your point the idea here is
that they're playing this video clip of
zolensky being like children are dying
and and civilians are under attack and
the translator is going
we must fight
for our children's freedom
and i'm just like that person should be
fired no no joke that person should be
should be uh maybe not five that's a
little harsh they shouldn't leave well
if if i were the boss and we were doing
a live translation broadcast i'd go up
to the guy and i'd be like let's let's
get you in here man get your cup of
coffee once you have a seat breathe a
little bit and we'll get someone in here
who can hand you know no disrespect this
is the translator crying because i've
seen this so i it's funny the trending
you're talking about i actually i follow
a bunch of lefty accounts to get their
side of things and i saw your tweet
screenshotted like four times before i
even saw your original tweet and um this
comment was from a bigger account saying
the thing that really pisses me off
about this war is the leader of the
country being invaded saying he thinks
it's bad that kids are being killed like
i'm so that's what they're suggesting
you're saying right well i don't care
about those people like it's it's like
if you like so they didn't watch the
video in the original of course
and they did it on purpose
because if you actually watched the
video you'd be like oh
it's not the president who's talking
because i don't understand ukrainian
it's some it's an eu translator who's
crying as he's talking and so my point
is
what they're trying to do with a lot of
this propaganda is appeal to your
emotions to get you to join a war effort
yes of course the the zealot pro-war
lunatics are going to come after me for
whatever i tweet i tweeted a very
obvious joke i mean of anyone who's
smart enough to understand it's zilenski
doing the the red salute i don't
actually want to do it but the communist
salute and um i said you know i said
whoa the president of ukraine just did
the communist salute or maybe he's
supporting black lives matter i can't
tell if he's supporting communism or
critical race theory like
and they're so ethan klein of h3 was
like he's actually trying to claim that
ukraine's president is a communist
because he's using the international
sign of resistance or whatever and my
response was uh you're gonna love this
it was it was a great response i said
thanks ethan big fan
i don't care whatever man so yeah tim is
actually a big fan can you believe this
i know could you believe it you know
well here's what i'm thinking somebody
some some people actually responded to
the left accurately on this
and they were like
someone said it's a joke chill and
they're like well i can't tell it's a
joke and so he needs to blah blah blah
and then someone responded
tim believes that taking twitter
seriously and engaging with people is
ineffective and it's healthier just to
tweet it all i could like treat it all
like it's unserious and a big joke and
that's uh that's fairly accurate it
might as well be because even the
serious accounts that are verified the
mainstream media they're just being
serious but spreading misinformation as
well so if you take it seriously you're
almost in a worse position if you take
everything you read on twitter seriously
i've said this before twitter is a
terrible website when you are having um
a good day on twitter it's because you
said something mean to someone and
everyone thinks you're funny when you're
having a bad day on twitter it's because
someone said something mean to you and
everyone thinks that's funny that's what
the website is for i'm just being cruel
i tweeted absolutely deter sarcasm speak
with honesty because emotions people are
bouncing on a needle's point about to
lose it i tweeted that out because i
keep seeing a lot of people i follow on
twitter are joking right now like being
sarcastic and it's not translating in
text yeah and just confusing people did
you see the girl that did the poem to
putin oh or she was like if i were
putin's mother i would have helped if i
was your mother i would have held you
tight putin you would have had mommy
monkeys it would have been all okay
that is not family she she got
absolutely like obliterated i kind of
feel bad is she serious she was being
serious but she was trying to be like
artistic and and like she she actually
is like a good soul you can tell she's
trying to be nice but it it doesn't work
on twitter this website is for
emotionally destroying that is like the
ultimate i can fix him yeah it really is
i can fix booting
it is you know what you know you know
what they don't like about me on twitter
is that you're right it's for
emotionally destroying people and they
have no power over me so someone someone
tweeted at me an image of it's the npc
meme but it's me wearing the baseball
tee and the beanie that was hilarious
and so i posted on instagram because i
think it's funny and there's a bunch of
funny ones there's one where my it's me
but my head's a blimp and it's got a
beanie on so good so it's like i'm in a
hot air it's a hot blonde i'm in a hot
air balloon of my own brain
with a basket that i'm standing in
and a little beanie on top and i'm like
i think that's great
my favorite though was uh the the
patriots.win formerly the donald have
been making all of these really funny um
anti like these memes about the
propaganda coming out of ukraine
so like the ghost of
kiev and like so they've been like the
cuck of kiev is mitt romney or whatever
but they made one where it was like this
is the fence sitter of kiev
his sitting on the fence has held the
russian forces at bay and they
superimposed my face over some ukrainian
soldier
and then in the comments they were like
i hope tim sees this because he's going
to laugh and then i put you know true
well
i'm like dude
that's that's the thing like i'll go on
twitter and they can say literally
anything and
that you when when ethan kline tweeted
at me like what what am i supposed to do
what does any regular person supposed to
do when someone's just making up stuff
or insulting you or you're supposed to
you're supposed to drop your jaw and
stutter and not have response
because you just got out sometimes to
happen sometimes people retweet the the
one that they have issues with and then
explain why it's wrong i i didn't like
that because it's like then you're
retweeting the person you disagree with
i'd rather just ignore it they just
retweeted it with haha
there's um that great anecdote where
it's like if if you get in the ring with
them someone is just trying to pull you
down it's like you're getting in the mud
pit with the pigs and you just get dirty
and the pigs just get happy whereas
you're kind of standing on the sideline
have fun pigs i like you yeah enjoy you
know i don't know what i'm going to do
next time i'm going to you know you know
what i should have tweeted i'm thinking
like you i obviously can't respond with
like here's my actual argument
like that's stupid nobody cares so i
just said thanks to ethan a big fan
because like i'm trending now thanks to
him you know what i mean there you go i
think next time i'll just put i'm sorry
that's it
i publicly apologize i'm publicly
impossible on your podcast
i wouldn't say that no but like the
point of the apology is they would be
like is he being serious do you think
you could hashtag i'm sorry to trend
yeah let's see if you can you can pull
it off i feel like i i apologize
for for for being wrong do a public
apology and then like plug raid shadow
legends or something like
they reached out to sponsor me and then
they like looked at my channel and they
were like oh we made a mistake
that was an accidental email
there's a hilarious meme of putin uh
it was obviously a fake translation of
his uh him speaking in russian and it
just was a long troll into saying that
his invasion of ukraine was just a
hilarious advertisement for rage shadow
oh i saw that
it's him talking
and there's like text and he's like i
did all of this to generate massive
global attention for a very important
issue rage shadow legends available now
we did it we had a joke james i don't
know if if if i i don't know if you ever
see this the the the fouchy youtube one
should we mention no no we can't say
that one no that that's okay yeah yeah
yeah that was a good one or the one
where he's just trying to follow up with
zelenski on his taxes or something
what what happened well so tim and i
wrote some we we did some funny improv
some funny jokes which is going to be
for for uh my supporters behind the pay
wall because it would absolutely get us
deleted from youtube forever
all right guys well you can't do that to
people i want to say i can
i absolutely can thanks for checking out
this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm we'll see you all there